madame monsieur bonsoir du cinéma à la
santé avec l'évasion spectaculaire d'un
détenu qui purgeait une peine de 18 ans
de réclusion criminelle du cinéma parce
que tout y était l'hélicoptère le toit
de la prison et même une femme qui
semble être au coeur de l'opération
c'était à 10h45 ce matin c'était en
plein paris voici le récit de roland
sicard et de bruno le dreff
la belle en hélicoptère le rêve le
projet quasi mythique de tous les
détenus
l'un d'entre eux l'a réalisé ce matin en
plein coeur de paris
l'opération avait été impeccablement
préparer ce matin une pilotes confirmés
qui prétend s'appeler l'ena rigon se
présente à l'aérodrome de saint cyr
l'école un terrain où elle est
considérée comme une habituée elle est
venue de plusieurs fois loué des
hélicoptères ou est ce l'une en
particulier elle allait faire des
balades et les menus quelquefois seul lé
mieux quelques fois avec des amis disons
qu'à la même cadence d'environ deux fois
par mois
la semaine dernière elle nous a retenu
sept hélicoptères pour faire un vol
local d'environ une heure aujourd'hui
elle est venue on lui a aidé à sortir la
machine à machine a été préparé pendant
le temps qu'on peut préparer la machine
elle avait son passager qui attendait
dans la voiture quand la machine était
finie elle a fait signe à son passager
devenir comme c'est habituellement le
passager monté dans l'hélico et l'hélico
a décollé
10h27 direction paris silence radio
le survol de la capitale est interdite
mais incontrôlable
les immeubles forme un formidable écrans
radar le bruit de l'appareil couvre le
quartier de la santé un filin et un
stack isolant un pistolet mitrailleur
pompe dans une cour de la prison
le détenu menace les gardiens s'accroche
koffi l'un escaladent le mur fusco toi
là l'un des hommes hésitent ils
renoncent l'eau michel vaujour plus de
dix condamnations trois fois il fait des
trois fois repris s'accroche au patin de
l'hélicoptère qui s'envole laliberté
rouge est monté leur écot perd quelqu'un
l'a aidé à l'intérieur semble les pas
mal de difficultés l'autre qui était
derrière n'a pas eu le temps de monter
hélicoptère aussitôt est reparti en
direction du sud
l'hélicoptère se dirige alors vers la
cité universitaire précédant de quelques
minutes seulement la police un endroit
bien choisi vaste campus proche de la
prison de la santé et de la sortie de
paris là le groupe se sépare un homme
fons le seul vers une moto avec un
véhicule à cette hauteur à la hauteur du
passage clouté pensait retrouver nez à
nez avec une moto à l'arrêt un tiers de
la route au milieu de la route
voilà et on a vu un gars surgir de la en
courant
carrément sauté sur la moto un grand
boucle et les partis sur les chapeaux de
roue l'autre partie du groupe franchit
le boulevard périphérique sur cette
passerelle là une voiture l'attend
les fuyards disparaît ce label est
terminée la cavale commence oui une
évasion vous l'avez vu le fort bien
préparé les gardiens n'ont pas eu le
temps de réagir puisque la différence
des prisons modernes comme celle de
fleury mérogis rien n'est prévu à la
santé pour empêcher une évasion de ce
type d'ailleurs rappelez vous une
évasion du même genre s'était produite
début 80 à fleury merogis justement
c'était avant tout installer des films
de protection pour le garder sous les
gardiens ne sont pas en cause dans la
sphère d'aujourd'hui ce sont les prisons
françaises ne sont pas équipés contre de
telles opérations monsieur challandes
c'est pas un problème de personnel c'est
d'abord question moyens je dire
l'hélicoptère aujourd'hui est une
réalité et moment les prisons ont été
faites
n'hésitez pas mais je crois que c'est
surtout un problème d'organisation est
là aussi
de politique des mesures ont été prises
sous le gouvernement précédent c'était
le gouvernement mauroy en 82 qui ont
considérablement adouci mais régime des
prisonniers ils ont des grands criminels
les auteurs de ce crime le grand
banditisme
le résultat c'est que comme ils sont
mêlés à l'ensemble la population eh bien
ils ont pu s'évader comme ils l'ont fait
ce matin auparavant il n'aurait pas pu
parce que auparavant il était traité de
passion spéciale il était isolé et
enfermés dans des endroits où une
évasion comme celle de ce passage est
absolument impossible faut donc
réfléchir sur la validité des mesures
qui ont été prises par le gouvernement
précédent
les gouvernements précédents et
probablement revenir dessus
oui monsieur chalandon faisait
probablement allusion à l'instant au
quartier de haute sécurité les fameux
qhs supprimés par pierre mauroy
or il faut savoir que michel vaujour
n'était pas un prisonnier ordinaire
c'est un récidiviste de l'évasion
c'est même selon son avocat un
délinquant chevronné voici donc les
images de michel vaujour lors de son
procès un procès au cours duquel il
avait donc pris 18 ans de réclusion
criminelle
avant de s'évader aujourd'hui de la
prison de la santé au cours de cette
évasion rocambolesque
alors parmi les questions que suscite
cette affaire il y a bien sûr la
présence de cet hélicoptère cet
hélicoptère blanc son contrôle dans le
ciel de paris
cet appareil qui a donc pu s'approcher
de la santé sans que rien ne puisse être
fait pour l'intercepter alors même qu'il
refusait de s'identifier cela veut-il
dire que n'importe qui peut à simone et
ses affaires au dessus de la capitale
avec les risques qu'on imagine
c'est la question à laquelle répond
maintenant françois korber 24 heures sur
24 les approches du territoire national
et l'espace aérien français dont paris
bien sûr sont surveillés par les radars
de la défense aérienne
toute cette surveillance est coordonnée
et commandé par le centre d'opérations
des forces de défense aérienne de
taverny en région parisienne lorsqu'un
avion non identifié et ne répondant pas
aux appels radio des centres de contrôle
s'approche de nos frontières
saint verny
peut faire décoller des intercepteurs
comme ce fut le cas avant-hier avec
l'avion de tourisme anglais pour une
reconnaissance à vue tout d'abord
éventuellement une interception
c'est une mission classique aucun avion
ne peut survoler le territoire national
venant de l'extérieur sans autorisation
les vols civils à l'intérieur du
territoire ne sont pas gérés eux par le
contrôle aérien militaire
dans tous les cas le survol de paris est
interdite a fortiori à basse altitude
par l'arrêté interministériel du 20
janvier 48 des dérogations sont
accordées à titre exceptionnel aux
aéronefs civils ou militaires par le
secrétariat général à l'aviation civile
après accord de la préfecture de police
ces images de la patrouille de france ne
sont pas courantes les alpha jet de
cette unité le survolant
traditionnellement paris que le 14
juillet les dérogations accordées aux
aéronefs civils sont encore plus
exceptionnel et ne concerne que les
missions d'intérêt général nous nous
sommes rendu cet après midi à l'héliport
d'issy les moulineaux pour un vol à bord
d'un hélicoptère délit france qui assure
chaque jour les liaisons avec les
aéroports depuis bari les pilotes
connaissent parfaitement la
réglementation des vols au dessus de la
capitale
seuls les cheminements réglementaire
d'entre eux sur des cartons et de rente
a également autorisé en quelque sorte
fait voler ce sont les périphériques
commence à l'heure actuelle est quelque
fois la scène où deux autoroutes avait
le survol par l'humain de paris iv libre
interdite alors comment expliquez vous
que ce matin l'hélicoptère ait réussi à
pénétrer à l'intérieur de la zone
interdite
enfin il est évident que si vous êtes
comme nous à l'heure actuelle sont des
périphériques et vous voulez une
permettent une petite incartade
ce sont là des mois près de paris
le pilote de ce matin ne s'est pas
encombré l'autorisation et pour cause
c'était la complice de vos jours que se
passerait-il si un commando terroriste
décidé un jour d'utiliser un hélicoptère
ont largué une charge explosive sur
paris incontestablement il semble que
pour l'instant rien ne serait prévue
pour l'en empêcher
il n'est pas question bien sûr d'abattre
en appareils au-dessus de la capitale